ladies and gentlemen uh director david
leach and producer kelly mccormick
be careful getting on whatever you want
to do here we go
got it this is what
coordinators really do is they make sure
that you're safe he's like the safest
guy
how's everybody
uh hey
so i want to give to start things off i
want to give a huge thank you to imax
and to sony for letting us do the
screening and to you guys for coming out
for people that don't realize they flew
in
for what are you guys here for just a
few days yeah yeah we're we have to head
back to sydney soon so yeah friday but
yeah just a few days for the junket and
stuff yeah they are um so we got very
lucky getting them they're gonna do the
fall guy with ryan gosling in sydney
after this yeah yeah starting in october
so um jumping into uh how did you guys
actually decide that this was going to
be the next project
oh kelly
well we were looking for something that
um we could you know we had like the
film business had the opportunity to go
back to work sooner than a lot of
industries did for better or worse um
uh and considered non-ascension or as an
essential industry we were essential
workers at that time at the height of
the pandemic so and we really wanted to
get our film family back together and we
thought you know it would be great if we
could find some contained project that
um allowed for us to you know get going
sooner actually and safer to be honest
because it was actually we started
before the vaccine
came into play so we were figuring out a
lot of the rules and regulations to keep
people safe along the way so we thought
that that was a really good sort of idea
to do that and then this script comes
across our desk right around the same
time
and um it happens to be perfectly
contained and also gonzo and awesome
i read it first and
sort of forced david into doing it not
at all
no it was i mean it was a gun point but
it was not at all no we it was like a
challenge because we saw all these crazy
characters and it was like how are you
gonna service seven stories and um
we had a lot of conversations about like
how are we gonna
first of all logistically like she was
saying we're going to make it on a stage
at sony that sounded great
and then you start to really analyze the
protocols and then you're like yeah but
we're on a sound stage where we can
contain everybody we're also in a tube
where we're right next to each other so
it was also had its problems with covid
um but film crews figured that stuff out
and we
found great protocols great ventilation
we made the sets modular all those
things but back to why we did it and
didn't miss a day which a lot of people
were shutting down for long periods of
time at that point and our covid
specialist told us it was because we had
a really old crew
yeah she's like super boring and really
old
another crew was going out at night they
were all just going home and like you
know you know
you know bubbling up with their families
you know we weren't like rowdy i guess
so uh that's why we avoided covet
but no look it was great characters zac
okowitz had really made the characters
come to life from the book and we that
was our entry point into it the script
and then we went back and rediscovered
the book and the great stuff that kotor
osaka had in it and um
you know it was really it just made
sense it was really in our wheelhouse of
stuff we love to do for people that
don't realize you were brad's stunt
double for a long time uh and i i
definitely want to ask you you were you
worked as brad's double on fight club if
i'm not mistaken
yeah
i know
well it was really he did and they've
talked about it a bunch on the junket
and there was one really cute thing that
happened during our junket where brad
and a couple of the um cast were talking
about stunt movies and if you know uh
you know and and they just brought up
out of the blue like oh you know that
thing in born ultimatum where the guy
runs through all the windows and he's
like chasing and you know the camera's
chasing him and he jumps and all this
stuff and i was like yeah i go yeah that
was david leech and they're like no way
it was so cool i was like oh yeah that
was your director
but
so yeah even with brad like on that that
first fight club movie was like a huge
moment for me i had been doing a lot of
television buffy the vampire slayer fans
in here anybody
yeah i wore a lot of prosthetic makeup i
was killed about 47 times
on those tv shows but then i ended up
i got a chance to work on fight club as
one of the sort of fight choreographer
trainers um david fincher really wanted
the actors to get in there and um learn
the physicality of fighting there wasn't
a lot of fights in that movie right but
it was more of like
he wanted the intention from those guys
so we were training brad and they're
like you know we need a double
and was standing next to him and they're
just all like what about him yeah he'd
be great and then wow you know he was a
lot skinnier then
wow
ouch
i was
but five movies later we we you know we
went on a run we did mr mr smith we did
troy
um
and we had you know great times around
the world doing really cool big movies
so the mexican great the mexican yeah
great well what i'm curious about is
everyone in hollywood is looking to cast
brad in a movie he is he gets sent every
script in town and it's basically you
know he gets offered everything so do
you think did your history
uh give you the leg up to getting him in
this movie had you been talking about
you know working together for a while
we had you know we um i was really
um
humbled to find out like he'd been
watching you know my career since i
started to move into second unit
directing and directing and obviously
john wick atomic blonde he knew those
things
we reunited on deadpool 2 for that cameo
and he was like um you know he was a
huge fan of the first film and he was
also a fan of ryan's and so to get him
to do that
we got to reunite again and he was just
starting to see me as a filmmaker so
yeah then it was a touch point like hey
we should find something
well he also sent a spy in
because uh during the hobbs and charis
shoots he has this old time um
i mean since the beginning of time i
should say a makeup artist named jeannie
black who's like amazing and david and
she were friends back in the day too
and um she came in and did
jason's makeup on our reshoots
bob's in shaw she's usually not
available she does julia roberts she has
all these people she's always busy and
she came and she's she says i'm spying i
gotta see if leech has got it i think he
might
and so i really think she had something
to do with it as well
yeah jeannie we've always been close i
mean because again like that time he's
she's been with him forever and um
for sure i think she definitely if she
puts in a word it means something in his
world and um
yeah she we had a blast on hobbs and
shaw and i think she saw
the way i run a set and the way i work
with actors and that brad might like
that experience but
ultimately i think it came to the
material and you know if you get a
chance to ask him and he's been talking
about it in the tour it's like he really
responded to the script too and he is a
material first guy and
he loved the characters and he loved
sort of the irreverent idea of what this
movie could be
and try to make something fresh and
original
and that was why he responded i'm gonna
throw a curveball right now uh i meant
to ask this at the beginning if you guys
and listen obviously people want to be
in business with you guys you you've
been pretty you've been on a roll with
films but is there if you could get the
financing or the ip to do anything what
would you make and why
it's hard i mean look i'll i'm gonna i'm
gonna dodge this question but i'll then
i'll answer it i think um
what's been really fun with bullet train
is like having a now a chance to express
myself outside of like two different
franchises or franchise expansions or
whatever you want to call hobbs and shaw
like those were really great experiences
with great people and
put different creative constraints on me
as an as a storyteller but also um
you know gave me resources i never would
have if i wasn't in that space but
bullet train was so fun because the ip
was relatively unknown obviously
here
and we got to do something that was
really original so
finding those ideas and and um really
getting to express yourself is like
what's interesting to me um but i do
have like there's a lot of ips that
are out there and that i've always
wanted to do um and i've circled some in
the past and i've attached to some and
they fell out and like
and i would just hate to soil
their names because i hope they come
back again
like i don't wanna i don't want to
dangle them out there to the universe
and like god i wish i could do that
because you know maybe they'll come
like there are there's stuff kelly do
you want to answer
no i am saying i think
there's too much pressure and there's a
lot of you know i mean there's so many
amazing stories to tell and
some to retell and you know it's it and
i i just kind of believe that like
you know i sort of we don't really do
that five-year plan thing we just sort
of like look at some things that really
sing to us in the moment and try to go
with that and
um so far we've been really lucky that
way with with both i you know known ip
and franchise and then also originals as
well
so you touched you touched on it a
little bit but i think that to be very
clear for people that don't realize like
96 of this movie was shot on the sony
backlot on a sound stage so um
talk a little bit about how using
technology to help tell this story was
it you know i believe i read that you
were using old school projection with
new tech led i mean can you sort of take
us through like how did you pull it off
doing all of this on the back you know
on a sound stage yeah i'll get into it i
mean that was part of the problem
opportunity i'm
by nature i think my years of being a
second unit director i
am more of organic filmmaker like i want
to go to the location and then i want to
be inspired by the location and i want
to shoot in that location and i want to
bring the crew to that location
and so i don't i'm not the the bringing
me to a stage is kind of like the last
thing i want you know um but we didn't
have a choice right so it really was an
opportunity for me to explore some of
the new technology um
the first thing we explored was the
um
the virtual production screens you know
virtual re virtual um
[Music]
the led stuff or the led led walls like
they had in mandalorian uh lux machina
came and
you know we worked with unreal engine um
ultimately we found out we didn't need
to track the cameras i mean the parallax
wasn't
this is getting technical but it wasn't
so much that we felt like we had to
track the camera with unreal so we were
really just using the led technology and
we
shot plates before production
of the trip from tokyo to kyoto and we
augmented them because you can see it's
a stylized version of japan but we did
all that augmentation and adding the
light and color correction and adding
buildings and things but we created this
journey in 3d
and then we just projected it on the
outside of the windows so
every shot is like you're shooting on a
train you know you never uh there's no
comp blue screen comps like that's all
just in camera with
rear screen projection but the new
version of that which is led monitors
right yeah people got motion sickness
because it was like they really felt
that they were on the train a lot yeah
there were actors that just didn't like
it and there were others that felt it
was really immersive i mean the things
that it gets you from a technical side
is like you get a lot of interactive
light and all the kicks off all the
surfaces like it's stuff you can't
create
in visual effects
that inter or it's really difficult to
create
that type of interactive light
without
having light
and now you have a comp and the light
it's actually a pretty
pretty
spectacular tool
i think it worked too to the
movie itself in the sense that it's a
heightened world it's a fable you know
when you first read it it's like oh my
gosh we're going to go to japan and this
is going to be amazing and that i think
that version is much more grounded you
know naturally and i think the movie for
us is a fable it's like
um you know not supposed to you're
supposed to be taken away and go for you
know all of the philosophical you know
sojourns that are happening on the train
and um i think that actually the
you know being forced to
shoot like in you know the leds and
virtually allowed for you to really
maximize that feeling um of it being
just heightened and not of this world
kind of
for sure i mean it actually led us to a
lot of the design of the movie in terms
of like the color palette and the
heightened style and even being in that
environment with color palette
heightened style heightened costumes it
just the tone of the movie lifted when
the characters came on set when the
actors came on set and like
you know we really felt that that mood
changed and we were in a live-action
anime sort of vibe that's what we were
going for you have worked with your dp
jonathan's is it salah salah
my bad uh you've worked with jonathan on
all your projects so how did you
ultimately first decide you wanted to
work with jonathan and talk a little bit
about working with him on this on the
color aesthetic and what you were going
for and what you wanted each car to look
like
um first time i worked with jonathan was
one of my first second unit jobs it was
on a um midnight meeting midnight me
train it was a horror movie with um
bradley cooper bradley cooper yes you
got it
um and you hey kitamura was the director
who i absolutely love and um jonathan
was this incredible dp he's really quiet
he's got um and he's very meticulous and
he has great composition and on that
movie i was just like
fascinated with his
choices of composition and so it always
stuck with me and we had a great
relationship even though he wasn't my dp
he was the first unit dp
when chad and i got the opportunity to
direct john wick i said we've got to
call my friend john cella and he's like
i don't know john cello who's john cena
and then i showed him midnight meat
train and then i showed him the die hard
that he'd shot and he's like holy [ __ ]
we gotta call jonathan zella
and jonathan has this extensive um he's
kind of um
a legend in the music video world so he
comes from a super stylized
upbringing in cinematography so
we love to dabble in color and
heightened color
and cool composition and camera moves
and and we really have fun as that as
part of our narrative toolbox
we often do a color palette for all the
scenes
from john wick atomic blonde they've all
had color wheels of like what we want
the scenes to be and how it's going to
arc through the movie and
bullet train was no different you know
we worked closely with production
designer david schumann who's been on
all of our films since atomic blonde and
it's sort of our
color geek fest we love it
yeah i mean maybe the next one will be
more natural we'll see i think the the
um to the second part of your question i
think one of david's trepidations
entering the project at all was how he
was going to entertain anyone for two
and a half two hours to uh anna it's
actually two hours good job it's two
hours i just made it
um that uh you know how are we gonna
entertain them they're gonna be on a
train the whole time it's gonna get you
know really sort of tedious and
so
it was critical to create worlds within
each train and
train car and so you know hopefully you
feel a lot different when you're in the
um economy car versus the first class
car versus a lounge versus like you know
and and and momomon which is my favorite
car
and sometimes the action that's
happening there or the emotion that's
happening there fits within the you know
vision of that car and sometimes it's
completely juxtaposed to it but that was
sort of really important to the design
of the movie
you guys have bad bunny in the movie and
uh
uh how good is that guy how good is that
guy come on like bad bunny what what
right
but the thing about it is you couldn't
have known he's gotten even more popular
since filming this movie kelly mccormick
knew
i didn't know i didn't know you totally
knew
that was her big that was one of her
many big ideas i i'm not under that was
like a huge idea like i had this vision
of
this grizzled old
um
the wolf like he's had and he lost the
love of his life like he'd been with for
you know 20 years and like it was this
old grizzled passion and she's like nah
you we need to like find the young
passion it's first love like that wolf's
gonna be way more tragic and i'm like oh
who are you thinking and she's like i've
been talking to mary renew great casting
amazing legend legend had said that bad
bunny had done this stint on narcos and
so kelly's and also his music videos and
also his songs i mean there's so much
passion in all of it and he performs so
well and like it's just he's just a
natural performer i think and so i was
like i think we should go for him
yeah we got we we reached out we got on
a zoom um he read over the weekend and
he's a you know he's a rock star but he
read over the weekend and he's like i
don't get to work with brad pitt i'm
like yeah this could be really fun like
come on let's do it and he's like okay
yeah and he came um
like a consummate professional i think a
lot of those guys are
that's how they get so successful i mean
his work ethic is off the charts and
he came and trained with us for three
weeks to work on the fighting and then
we had to shoot that whole
you know this non-verbal you know story
that i wanted to tell visually
you wanted to build up the expectation
of this character and obviously rip the
rug out and um
so he was with us for three four weeks
yeah actually i think we had a covet
hiccup in the middle of it and had to
switch some stuff around so he had to
come back and he was like just
absolutely in for it all worked his
booty off i mean he's such a pro we love
that guy so much and we've gone to his
concert since and we are the only people
who go
we are the oldest bad bunny fans
but his concerts are awesome and he's so
amazing in november everybody knows
every word it's so cool
uh i am curious though so you there's a
lot of action in this movie obviously uh
talk a little bit about how early on
before production begins are you
like staging these sequences and working
with stunt teams and can you sort of
like take us through like how early are
you doing all this be you know
i mean it depends on the movie i mean
bullet train was its own animal i think
um
because of kovid we had a lot less time
to prep
and
luckily you know the the scenes on this
train were really in my wheelhouse it's
like
fighting stunts it's like things
i've been doing for
30 years and so i had a lot of uh ideas
and i had the tone where i wanted to go
we were sort of like this homage to
jackie and buster keaton and all of
those
fun physical um
comedy beats that we were trying to we
were trying to get so um i think we had
eight weeks with the stunt team
which
again is not a lot for a big stunt movie
like it really isn't a lot um but again
it was really fight based stuff and so
they were working in masks and the weird
protocols that we had at that time and
everyone has to test every day and it
was just a weird
because
choreography is tactile like it's like
people in a room
kicking and punching each other trying
stuff choke this guy that choke doesn't
work try this you know oh where's the
comedic moment hands in the face and all
that stuff during covid before the
vaccine was all weird even
for stunt people they're like
somebody test positive and everyone was
like freaking out and
um so we took this
this was very methodical and very
different like a big movie
you know these big action movies and tim
would know like you do months of
pre-biz and
you know rehearsing with
you know your stunt team and they're on
for they can be on for you know three
four or five months
we're talking about someone in the
audience oh sorry i didn't know who's
texting i just roll out and shoot it
yeah i mean the other thing that was
different about this is usually you're
also a lot of times you're shooting with
the same character for
you know
in this case there were a lot of
characters came in and out or only had
one big sequence and so
you that allowed you to actually prep
for here's me talking as a producer is
budgetarily speaking like it allowed you
to prep a little bit shorter at the
beginning of the movie because then when
the actor would come in you would need a
few days with that actor to get them
primed for what they were to do with
their scene as it was coming up so it
was it was very episodic that way the
movie is a bit episodic like the train
the whole production train there the
train is rolling
literally figuratively down the track
but you're only shooting these two
actors those other actors are off they
can be rehearsing the stunt team's on
for the whole movie so they go to a
different place and they
so the your shooting time is off in prep
time yeah it's hard for a director
because you're like what's going on
where's that choreography i want to see
that has it changed but you're trying to
focus on the scene
you try and get as much prep done as you
can in the beginning of the movie but it
undoubtedly
keeps rolling downhill and you're
prepping and shooting until the very end
but maybe it's just me
he just rolls out of bed and shoots
um who do you i don't know if and i
apologize for not knowing did you have a
second unit director on this yeah gregor
mentor yeah who was with us on hubsan
shaw as well i was gonna say how listen
you've obviously done second unit and i
would imagine are you do you consider
yourself to be a micromanager or do you
consider yourself to be like you know i
trust my second unit director i don't
i'm good
i trust them you know i i totally trust
them because we've already gone it's
generally
the guys that second unit for me are
usually from my fight world
and they've been my on my choreography
team and we've done a lot of stunt viz
already or previs and we know what the
sequence is so
they're going to get the pieces we all
agreed upon and if they
they get inspired and they shoot
something else
you know it's i'm usually fine with it
because they're guys that have i've been
working with for a long time you know
there's other movies you know and hobbs
and shaw
i had a really great opportunity to work
with simon crane and he did some great
stuff in
in
scotland for a sequence in that and so
it's a very different thing on a big
massive movie like that when there's
moving parts of like you know i have a
splinter unit here and a second unit
where i am and then i have to send a
unit away
um you just have to have trust in people
and that they're
had the right conversations and you get
good stuff
uh i do you actually think a hobbes and
shaw sequel will ever happen
i hope so i mean i think those guys
together are awesome i mean i hope so i
um i don't i don't i'm looking at kelly
and i'm i'm trying to well she's like i
don't want to bet on it i don't know
what the odds are i mean they're so busy
everyone's so busy um but man i think
people had a lot of fun and those two
guys together are fire for sure yeah
that's the kids are saying fire fire
yeah
i've heard at times that they're in
development on something but we haven't
seen anything
the biggest problem with with duane is
um you know what is he scheduled out for
two years yeah
yeah he he goes deep on his schedule and
he's got a lot of stuff
yeah um so you know and everyone in this
room who's seen a q a with me knows that
i like talking about the editing process
because it's where it all comes together
uh which of your films actually changed
the most in the editing room that in
ways you were not expecting
[Music]
atomic blonde
yeah you think i don't know what were
you gonna say i don't know
nobody changed a lot in editing actually
yeah nobody nobody actually i mean it's
a film we produced but that transformed
during the edit can you can you is there
a like
there's one sequence that i could
probably share about it so uh the
director's cut um you know has ever
anybody seen it some people have seen it
in kirkland
if if you remember the opening of that
movie where it's like monday tuesday
wednesday thursday friday you know and
it's like really the perpetual sort of
like drone of our lives and how you miss
the garbage and all the [ __ ] that
happens all week
so that uh
actually david and i conceived of after
the director's cut like so not to take
anything away from elia because that's
crushed but
he
was you know it was starting kind of
where the movie starts after that was
where it started which is kind of like
into the family stuff and getting to
know the family as they go and all that
kind of stuff and the movie to us was
like critical to understand that for for
us the movie's about
um you know that drone that people get
into that like you know you settle into
this life you you know thought you were
going for the american dream you don't
really do it anymore you kind of go to
the humdrum you haven't really figured
it out and then you know something
triggers you that like shakes you out of
that like monotony and makes you kind of
a better person
through violence
awkwardly but um no but that was you
know that
you couldn't get that sort of rhythm of
like the regular life and the um drum of
like what we all go through when you
watched it you know when we were sort of
watching the director's cut and so we
pitched ilya that idea
and didn't do any additional photography
we just used the same footage to make it
feel even more
monotonous
and um that i thought changed the movie
so significantly and made it really kind
of really connecting in that way um that
to me was like one of the biggest things
that we've changed yeah you you make me
think of something because the way you
enter a movie is so crucial um
and i'll i don't know i mean it's
one of the things that happened
editorially with bullet train is that
the original script was it told in
character chapters for the first uh two
reels so you meet a character you go all
the way back and then you meet another
group of characters and you go all the
way back you mean another group of
characters and you'd see them all walk
past each other
and so the way we had shot it
you would always see the other
characters in the other person scene but
you'd stay with those characters
and we were just feeling the we really
wanted to get into the movie faster we
wanted to be with ladybug sooner we
wanted this momentum to fall forward
they were also interconnected that
elizabeth
our editorial partner in crime who does
all our movies was like
we should intercut this stuff and like
just get on with it you know it's really
cool how they pass each other and let's
just go back and forth and people will
follow the narrative and it's gonna be
great so
she took a stab at it because i was a
little reluctant because i i like the
elegance of the chapters but then
once you see that change it becomes
undeniable you're like oh that's the way
the movie was supposed to be and um you
find all that stuff in post and that's
what i really love about post like you
can find
just some magic things that you never
thought
would change your movie did you have a
much longer like first cut did you end
up with a lot of deleted scenes
there's not a lot of deleted scenes
there's a lot of deleted material the
scenes were really long and um
i
this movie in particular i allowed this
sort of play
of improv obviously you can see aaron
taylor johnson brian tyree henry are
just having fun and like
their their characters are really
they're into their characters and they
are um
you know getting to the point
editorials helping us get to the point
of those scenes because they can chew it
up and it's funny and it's funny and
it's funny and there's so many jokes and
improvs on the cutting room floor and
you at some point you just gotta like
okay choose cause
i'm gonna choose this joke and move on
um
but no i think the scenes just through
great compression on elizabeth's part
there isn't many scenes that are gone if
any
i think they're all there they're just
the essence of what they need to be so
we're obviously in an imax theater and
uh this is being released in imax can
you sort of talk about uh the actual
format of imax and have you considered
um shooting in the future uh using you
know imax cameras for like filming
something in total
i think i mean the imax experience i
thought i mean i think this movie in
specific works really really well on
imax i think it's very it's such a
there's so much going on and then
um it's
there's it's you know they worked really
hard on the visual storytelling you know
like when we spot checked
uh the movie in imax we actually sitting
in here yeah and we ended up watching
the whole thing because it was just you
were seeing things that you hadn't seen
before
and um
like there's one moment if you remember
where lemon spots the you know the gun
with the bobby
hair bobble on it in the um
like a
backpack and you don't see that as
clearly on other screens it's just so
clear that like he's connecting those
dots and then you know you see him put
it back in and use his other gun and
that can be a little confusing if like
it's because it's so going so quite
quickly and you can just see it so much
more clearly it's just one example i
mean i think there's you know it in
specific is doing a lot just without
words and
um you know the visuals that i think it
is an incredible format for this film in
particular and i wouldn't have thought
that and you say that and i wouldn't
have thought about it that in the
beginning because you always think of
imax as like oh it's great for these
beautiful landscapes and these big scopy
shots and when we sat in this room i
just thought how compelling it is for a
movie like this there's actually
a lot of great close-ups and all this
intricate detail and things that you
have to follow but the large format
works incredibly well for it so um
it's expanding my mind actually having
this play so well in imax to like what
can i use it for and what would be
interesting and my storytelling to use
it for well the thing is like i look at
what jordan peele just did with nope and
i think about nolan and what he's doing
with oppenheimer and the other basically
listen i i love imax obviously i've been
doing a screening series here for
forever and so uh you know i like it
when filmmaker when i push filmmakers
and being like so do you think you're
about to shoot fall guy and he thought
about imax
you put us on the spot here at imax
right i do this on purpose
actually fall guy would look amazing in
imax it's gonna have some epic stuff in
it for sure yeah and i think that type
of movie actually now that you say it
steve
and we're going to get yourself we're
going to shoot sydney for city i'm
trying to talk you into it now too
it's all locations you know it's really
a location driven movie
and
we're going to be shooting practical
locations and we're going to be showing
the city of sydney and like
um
yeah i mean call peter kramer
no i mean look here we go
listen i i personally and i've said this
so many times i feel like and by the way
i do not get paid by imax this is just
my love of the format just to be very
clear um i just think it like you can't
recreate it at home like you look like i
have a decent tv and a decent sound
system i cannot recreate the experience
of going to a movie theater and being
submerged in this you know it's it's
[ __ ] awesome sorry for my language
no you're right and i think it again
like as we look for as filmmakers to
support formats that are gonna um
you know keep encouraging cinema to
bounce back and and to stay alive and
then
this is definitely one of the premiere
formats for that stuff yeah hopefully
you're leaving this theater with kelly
whispering in your ear you know
[Music]
before i run out of time with you guys
though um because i know we're gonna
nearing the end but like you guys have
87 north and i'm just curious what's
coming up over there that you're really
excited about
um this thing called violet night we
shot in winnipeg this winter which is uh
david harper playing santa who has lost
his christmas spirit and
he has to beat up the naughty list to
get his christmas spirit back as you do
and it's really fun it's really fun
universal i'm just gonna release it
around christmas time it's time you work
all the directing and um just a hoot
it's ridiculous it's so fun is it over
the top violent or just violent
i think it's over the top violent like
it's what's over there
over the top violence
it is
we're watching netflix squid game the
first people the first episode people
are getting executed and then uh you
know i have a few assassins die who are
complicit on a train really naughty guys
really naughty guys
these people are like not that many guns
i mean like
i was surprised when we got the response
like wow really
i will say that not every even though
squid game is super popular not everyone
has seen it that
it sounds like everyone's seen it
i have actually not seen someone what
you need to watch oh you guys
listen it's so good
wow so many hours in the day i didn't do
a junket it's uh i don't see the cracks
but listen
but besides besides that i know you guys
are cooking up other stuff and i know
you opened like an office in hollywood
for training like talk a little bit
about that yeah we did we um you know we
didn't have an office before covid and
then uh when things uh sort of felt like
they were settling down it was sort of
like let's all get back to
work and the executives really wanted to
and we've always wanted to open another
facility that's like you know sister to
the one that uh david and chad share is
down here in inglewood and so we were
like let's do something sister to it
like closer to
where people live
no
i love england don't get me wrong
but like you know in sort of hollywood
sort of like more by where the studios
are so that maybe they can use it as a
training facility as well and it was
really hard to find a place and then
um i was just looking around on uh you
know
a loop net if you've heard of it and
it's like this like uh you know place to
look for like commercial spaces and
there was this like church and i was
like that had been converted um into
this kind of modern looking space and
completely just kind of renovated into
just an openness with these beautiful
windows and i just was like we got to go
check this place out and then it ended
up being available we ended up uh like
converting it even more putting a stunt
floor in and a bunch of uh training
equipment and our executives work out of
there as well and people call it the
church of pain it's
and it's really inspiring and also and
kind of zen at the same time or it's
like ladybug it's spiritual yeah it's
it's a path to enlightenment there you
can learn action and uh you know but you
can put peace out in the world too it's
still a church you know yeah
so um uh talk a little bit though um
storyboarding versus finding it in the
moment when you're on set how much are
you guys like pre-visiting the entire
thing or you know what i mean like yeah
um
for me i work the way i work with
jonathan is we shot list and we talk
about the composition
um i do what i use storyboards is for
exploration i mean i have some great um
storyboard artists one i've been working
with recently will grobe like
since deadpool like i explore sequences
from the script like before
pre-production
starts but i can keep him on contract
and i can workshop ideas and just say
sketch out this idea for me because it's
one person that can give me some visuals
but once i get into production
for me that starts to go away because i
see the location i know the set i'm
sitting there with jonathan we're going
to be here we're going to be there we're
going to be a close up here it's going
to be a 35 there and we're just we're
shot listing and it's very particular
it's like storyboards but
i don't feel like i need the boards
anymore because i know
i see that the picture is already in my
head if i have the words
so it's not but it's very detailed like
i don't um
i i like to start out like that and then
what happens ultimately is you have an
actor come in and they have an input and
you're like oh that's a better idea and
then part of that switches
where you want to block something
and then you adjust to that
but maybe 75 of it changes but i'd love
to have the plan just coming into the
day i got
20 setups these are exactly what i want
and then if it changes great
but i have a plan
i i totally understand um uh i apologize
for saying this but i believe we have to
stop this q a because you have to go
somewhere and
and uh yeah uh do we have time for a
couple of questions or
yeah yeah
oh yeah definitely but um yes we have a
ball does anyone have any questions
oh yeah um let me give it to a tim right
there come on tim right
we wait no we need the ball where's the
ball
for people that don't realize um just
real quick for for people that don't
know uh tim directed the first deadpool
and this guy directed the second
deadpool so it's a it's a deadpool
family here so cute wasn't it existing
without you brother you're very kind
um the is back to editorial again
because i wondered because you were all
in one location because you had i
imagine standing sets for all this did
it change the editorial process like
were you able to not have a lot of
reshoots because you could go back and
pick up little pieces and it's really
intricate with lots of little inserts to
connective tissue um
a little a beautiful little puzzle there
did it help by
having all that stuff did it change the
process um i like having standing
i like having standing sets for that
reason like splinter unit you know or
like um you can go back i think um on
every one of my films it's always like
the last day on stage is like um
mayhem 17 different pieces of set that
are brought back out to the stage for an
insert that's i'm thinking i need
um
we didn't have
did we do any additional photography on
bulletin no we didn't do anything we
didn't do any additional photography on
bullet train but we did have one of
those days where it was like last day of
school and get out the train cars re you
know make this feel like the bar car
make this feel like the and um you know
put some smoke and smashes here for the
knife pickup like brad was in like 20
sets that day
and that's the fun thing about stage is
like all the control you have and like
to solve those problems and like you
know a set can live and you're right you
don't have to go back to a location and
now you're just reminding me that i'm
doing a location movie [ __ ]
i have to go back to all those places
tim i'll never get that [ __ ] no reshoots
with all that little intricate stuff was
impressive thank you um again it went to
the plan and the plan sort of
it worked you know we really we planned
and we talked about reshoots for
actually that's not true that button
with lemon is the one thing we shot
um
we didn't even need it tom rothman got
all obsessed that we had to have lemon
live again
and so he was like let's just go do this
and that's what we thought we were
inside about it too yeah we were super
excited so cute um and but yeah that was
the one thing we picked up which is a
coda so yeah yeah so we went and shot
that coda tom's idea so who cares yeah
you guys
he was like you should live we're like
that's a great idea will you pay for it
i wish we could squeeze a few things in
that we need
and i built a bunch of little sets and
shot inserts
let's do another uh do we have time for
another question
uh do we
right here yeah
um
are you talking to oh we're talking okay
i just had a question um first off great
movie probably one of the best i've seen
all year it's thank you so phenomenal
it's so great um
i saw that music was a big like deal
within the action set pieces and another
movie that does that really really well
is edgar wright's baby driver which is
one of my favorite movies of all time
and i was wondering if like did you have
any inspiration from that or like
like how important was music to you when
it came to writing the sequence fighting
sequences or just any of the scenes
yeah i you know music's always a big
part of what i like to do atomic blonde
is like the perfect example i mean the
soundtrack sort of drove the movie for
me visually and
the soundtrack i wrote into the script
and it really never changed it was like
in the dna of that movie so i do use it
as a jumping off point we have a great
composer on this movie uh dominic lewis
who
was super inspiring and he was creating
suites of music for the characters
before i started so i could we could
play them on set and i was trying to
find a um
sort of a needle drop vibe inside of in
the in the score so every song even it's
a piece of score it feels like a song
that you may know or something from the
past or different different types of
music but it felt like a song
and so that was our approach and we
created all these suites of material for
our characters and i played them and
we'd start to identify them and then he
would refine them and as we got into
post then we really refined it um so
yeah we it was um
a long process yeah there actually are
maybe fewer needle drops for david in
this one than usual and part of it was
because just dom was coming up with this
amazing stuff and we kept dropping
needle drops it was like that was so
much better than the idea yeah the wolf
the song for the wolf is an original
piece by dominic lewis and then we ended
up getting an incredible artist to sing
it alejandra sans who's a
credible latin singer he loved the song
so much he came on to record it for
himself
um
we just i don't know it was like one of
those fun creative explosions with dom
like
albert humperding scenes sings the um
bubbles in the 17 kills that guy's like
82 years old and he came in and recorded
the music and he put like bananas behind
his headphones because it's the way he
hears better and he's just such a legend
he's still performing and like he's such
a cool dude and we had a lot of amazing
singers come in for this one it's pretty
special yeah uh can we do one more or
are you one more one more um that guy's
been raising his hand oh you guys pick
right here let's do it appreciate you
thank you of course
um amazing film by the way thank you
thank you uh it's a very simple question
uh i just i guess um i wanted to know
both of you uh who were your favorite
characters and what was your favorite
stunt achieved in this film who was
yours okay okay
this is great okay okay okay okay
okay so i gotta i gotta take
ladybug you know what i'm saying i mean
i have to take him out the way because
he's like amazing so i'm gonna say uh
i'm gonna say lemon yeah that's my grab
lemon
we have a big you know uh
we have a lot of feels for lemon for
sure um
he uh is like this you know these two
sociopaths come together and like they
have this brotherhood and you obviously
care about them it's so crazy like to be
in a movie like that and then
um they give me these performances
during their death scenes where i'm like
actually feeling something i'm like holy
crap and like i didn't want to undermine
it i wanted to just let you sit in it
even though this is a bonkers crazy
broad movie i wanted you to feel those
emotions with them because you know
the journey's more satisfying so
hats off to brian and aaron for their
characters
yeah for sure
i think we love all the characters it's
really hard to pick
um and that was the hope is that
somebody would connect to somebody in
one of these characters in some way or
maybe all of them in different ways and
that's what we're really trying to do
the elder's pretty cool too hero you can
yeah yuki's a badass he knows everything
um on that note i know you guys have to
go to something else so ladies and
gentlemen uh please uh david and kelly
thank you guys very much
[Applause]
you